Okay.
So
now we're going to talk about the
phenomenal logical existential slash
phenomenological psych guy trusts
and their theories from the 1950s.
And as I mentioned to you before,
a lot of their thinking was motivated
by what had happened in World War II.
When I,
when I lecture to you last,
I,
I pointed out,
I described Nietzschean Dostoyevsky's
summation of the world situation and
really the world psychological
situation at the end of the 18 hundreds.
And that was that
our new modes of thinking had undermined
our faith and our old modes of
thinking.
And that was a problem because people
need something firm to stand on,
to orient themselves and to move forward.
And so Nietzschean Dostoyevsky basically
both prophesied that the consequence of
that dissolution would be,
um,
increased probability of nihilism and
everything that went along with that.
And Dostoevsky wrote about that actually
quite extensively in a book called
notes from underground,
which if any of you are interested,
especially in clinical psychology,
that's a book you should really read
because it's one of the most brilliant
psychological studies of,
uh,
of,
psychologically disturbed
man that's ever been written.
It's very accurate.
And there are sections in crime and
punishment that are like that too.
I think there are unsurpassed
in their representation of,
of psych,
of psychological phenomena.
I don't,
I don't know how he managed it.
I mean,
Dostoyevsky was epileptic,
I don't know if you know that,
but he,
um,
he was arrested by the czar's men in
the late 18 hundreds for being a student
radical and they throw them
in the main prison in Moscow.
And then one day they took them out in
front of a firing squad and shot him at
six in the morning,
but they only use blanks,
which of course he didn't know about.
And that scared him so badly.
He developed epilepsy
and then he had epilepsy.
That can happen by the way.
Um,
if Andy had epilepsy for
the rest of his life,
but he had this strange kind of epilepsy,
which is actually not all that rare.
Um,
sometimes when people have epilepsy,
they experienced this phenomena.
They call an aura,
which is an altered state of consciousness
before the epileptic seizure hits.
And they can be very strange these auras.
So I read a case study
once about a guy who,
um,
his aura was that his hand was
being possessed by devils from hell,
and he could feel the possession move
up his arm and into his shoulder.
And once it hit his head,
he'd have an epileptic seizure.
And so then there was another case,
um,
where,
where this man,
his aura was that his exact
double had appeared behind him.
But if you turn it,
and if you turn to look,
then he'd have an epileptic seizure.
But if he didn't turn to
look that he wouldn't.
So these brain disorders are very
strange things because they're,
well,
the system that is disordered is alive
and it's capable of any number of
extraordinarily peculiar misbehaviors.
Anyways,
Dostoyevsky's aura was
a world revealing aura.
And so what Dostoyevsky would experience
was that the meaning of things got
deeper and deeper and deeper
and deeper and deeper.
And then just as he was on the verge of
discovering the secret to everything,
he'd have an epileptic seizure.
But he said that the quality of
experience during the aura was so high,
so overpowering and so deep that he
would have traded all of his normal
experience just to have had those
experiences and have them repeatedly.
And I really do believe that
it was this broadening of his,
of his vision and concept by his
epilepsy that transformed them.
Among other things.
I mean,
he went through some pretty damn rough
experiences because he was in prison with
rapists and murderers for
a long time in Siberia,
even though he was kind
of an aristocratic guy.
I mean,
he had a,
he had a rough time of it.
And I,
I imagine that that also broadened him
tremendously given that it didn't kill
him.
But,
um,
I really do believe that the
epileptic insight was key to his,
like his unsurpassed genius.
And so,
and the his aura and other people do
experience epileptic or a symptoms like
that,
by the way.
And some people are so enamored of the
aura that they won't take their auntie
epilepsy medication because they don't
want to forego the experience that
precedes the aura or the actual
actual epileptic seizure.
So Dostoyevsky's experiences,
they,
the op element of the aura is also
relevant to what we're going to talk about
today because both been swagger and boss.
We're very interested in how meaning
revealed itself in the world.
And they had an,
they had opposing explanations.
I actually think they're
parallel explanations,
but the meaning that
Dostoyevsky experienced is,
is an amplification of the normal manner
in which meaning reveals itself in the
world.
So I mean,
and people experience that sort of
thing in various altered states of
consciousness.